[Music]
in favor Dimmick news a bit about
Frankie beat any cigarette users are
being warned to stop vaping after six
deaths from a mysterious lung disease my
brother quit cuz of the [ __ ] he was
addicted if this is getting real so they
really put nicotine in vape right yeah
all the time but most of these cases
here they're saying that it's connected
to the CBD like the THC not CBD THC vape
because there's this vitamin E in it and
it's a vitamin E it's an oil that you're
not supposed to be heating up and
putting it in your lungs because it ends
up reacting so a lot of these cases like
is it like they say how they die or just
getting your lungs that you just can't
breathe thank ya so there's people that
have to be on vent ventilators um some
of these people that have died though
that and why am I not sad for them
because I just imagined this [ __ ] boy
getting it and I come just saw some that
are older like there's like a 50 year
old woman mcgavock year old [ __ ] boys
are going all of these days they do age
yeah so I saw old lady with Balenciaga
and [ __ ] like I love see people I see
a girl she makes me laugh know the crazy
sanada's in a bit a commercial the other
day and it was for a vape like [ __ ] like
thing and it was like this hole and it
made babies seem so cool and I was like
they do this [ __ ] all the time I feel
like they did that with us when we were
kids like like I said I'm 40 like
everyone who's have the big candy
cigarettes
oh me too I love like they were like
yeah I'm a big league - and she was like
tobacco it's like no y'all [ __ ] this up
this [ __ ] was terrible we was doing this
[ __ ] thinking it was cool you're doing
it again I'm Mike in 15 years they're
gonna be like vaping his dog and there's
gonna be this big campaign
big non-smoking thing it's like all
money I copy people and said now like
this is a rerun I've seen this [ __ ]
before because even when I watched it as
a 40 like I was a 40 year old man I'm
watching like I want to do that what the
[ __ ] is the kid gonna do it tastes good
[Applause]
and you think it's not it doesn't say
that it smell like smoke because like
that's the negative you know annotation
like as far as with I watch my like
cigarette smoke
that's it was crazy
hey what do you think they're doing with
that possible [ __ ] yeah didn't want
everyone home did she's my wife in case
you don't the fall for it didn't he like
or like didn't he come out and be like
don't do it anymore I mean they're so
like did they stop no no they just
change their ads a little wiser no [ __ ]
shape foods cuz they don't want you to
our oysters your Adam there's no there's
no link there it looks like the most
dirtiest [ __ ] to it's like all [ __ ] I
would enjoy it very salty taste for
Steve I'll get there maybe animal
I'm connecting thoughts because you got
talking about big league chew and [ __ ]
my own trying to bring it back so can
you eat some [ __ ] and I think this is
just I feel like the whole industry is
just set up to just get our money and
kill us yes preach oh yeah open eyes I'm
telling you or opioids in a couple years
that's gonna be it's it's really really
big now cuz you guys know I had a
problem with drinking I'd go to rehab
for that [ __ ] like I don't drink at all
but like when I was in there I was in
there with people that because when you
do opioids the next step in progression
is heroin yeah that's all it is and like
that like how these doctors just giving
out these pills cuz I was talking to a
dude and he was based like he was like a
regular dude he was playing rugby he
hurt his knee he [ __ ] up his knee
which add up they started giving them
pain pills and he started abusing them
because it was feeling good then when he
ran out they were like no you're abusing
this we're not giving you no more then
he goes to the street start buying them
$25 a pill that runs out next thing how
is it not on the news every night about
this [ __ ] here's a challenge video for
you try to watch the news without seeing
a [ __ ] commercial for drugs regular
TV oh my god so why would they [ __ ] with
their own revenue stream no it's [ __ ]
up cuz then hair looks you too instead
like actually it gives them like it's
easier to access than the opioids so
that's why people move on and also I was
a small family number that went through
this they said that it they took could
take a lower dose of heroin to get the
same effect as opioid so they in their
mind it was justified as being like
better I'm saving money yeah which is
like what prolonged the addiction right
well can like if we lived in a different
dimension right where instead of our
government like you know conspiracy that
everyone's trying to make us sick and
like they make money off of killing us
like what what would it look like on the
flip side like if we're a healthy
society and like they're making money
off of us being healthy like what would
that be like we overpopulate
a lot of people need to die very for
people dying bro people dying no but you
think they want to make us live longer
so that we keep paying bills and [ __ ]
well I'm saying but they got they want
that fast money but it's way they don't
want the 1835 industry per specific
right because I feel like banks would
want people to live longer because more
debt right that they make more money but
then like the the pill factories they
want us to just use and abuse I think
because like we're built with a survival
mechanism like we want to survive as a
species so it's easier to make you sick
and make you want and then we're gonna
fight to survive then it is to make you
healthy and then you're not gonna fight
the war prevention yeah prevention is
like the key to not using needing pills
or anything that's the thing though
they'll never give you the cure because
the money's in the medicine so like
that's the thing to always have the
problem and how always about oh you need
this can I even had a friend that was
like hooked on pills and he was hooked
on pills so much like they're like they
had to put him on another pill to get
him unhooked from that girl so like how
is a pill the answer if you're like they
won't wait for you to like naturally let
this happen they induce you they give
you meds and then because of that first
meant to induce you then it causes this
other problem or another baby is like
having trouble breathing or like the
woman starts hemorrhaging or some [ __ ]
like it just creates a domino effect of
worse problems we can have more thing to
that bill it's for the bill but
ultimately is so they can just c-section
you up and like say like they could go
home so they don't under and like use up
a bed as you're giving birth if
something got cured bro exactly holy oh
god cured also check up here whens less
than someone got [ __ ] cured dude yeah
she's getting worse do you not just some
sick call super gonorrhea and that's it
like a couple of days who named some
[ __ ] they're like it's like we all know
the caller says super
think about a cape on my disease people
were kind of forgetting about gonorrhea
like it was getting left out yeah got a
remake up their image you have
congratulations you have super gonorrhea
right apparently you kidding it I don't
know if it kills you but you can't get
rid of it
get your ass not gonna be dating I'm
just gonna put my heart and soul into
work and I'll jack off on the webcam
that's well get one of those robotic
dick suckers and I'll just watch porn
and I'm like alright have you heard
about the meter showing yeah the the
interactive girlfriend's that they
become like the dogs they're like really
real like yeah the whole thing I still
have attitude like you know and I real
bunny
all the time and the next thing they say
is never funny yeah but I think it's
definitely money cuz you know what I'll
be thinking about all the time like when
I go into dispensaries and get weed I'll
be like there's so many people that went
to jail for this [ __ ] so many people
have probably still in jail right now
and this [ __ ] is super ly it's all about
money whatever just like well we could
probably make billions and dollars off
this well I called this [ __ ] in jr. it's
crazy
I had a [ __ ] huge argument with my
parents always like look this is just
money it's like our it's our prohibition
that's all that's that's all that's
going down once they figure out a way to
tax this yeah it's gonna be legal oh you
know what the next day's gonna be and
mark mark my words i'ma let into the
camera I says you know the next thing is
gonna be they're gonna come out with
some type of breathalyzers to find out
if you've been smoking marijuana
there's gonna be the thing everybody
that's all you make a so now they're
like oh we can sell it to him the UI is
a huge money million dollar industry
that's gonna be the next thing I mean if
they find out you smoking then that's
gonna be the next thing and smoking and
driving you know and they'll make
billion dollars off pulled over and like
we had drinks a couple hours before and
there was like a checkpoint and even
though it was like we're refined like
it's been enough time we were like oh
[ __ ] like is it cool like we were kind
of freaking out and then they they
rolled on the when they're like hey this
is just a stop to ask you if you've been
smoking pot tonight marijuana yeah it
was I'll hold my lemonade I'm like oh so
I'm cool I wasn't smoking not what's
drink and oh yeah that's a mess well if
you think about it right the way that
they get you is your lack of
self-control
right so they prey on the people that
don't have any self-control and that's
all of us got David it's harder [ __ ]
that are misguided and the hatful
misinformation yeah yeah that's true
because that's what happened that's
what's happening right now with the
whole vape epidemic because they're
saying that more than 450 possible cases
of lung illness associated with using
e-cigarettes has been reported to the
CDC across 33 states and the US Virgin
Islands and it's just increasing like
the numbers are increasing and there's
even people saying I'll show you photo
just in case I don't know what something
looks like oh you said the second one
yeah I was I was a very early adopter
right because this is before the vape
laws I would go into polka room
well you can't smoke inside anymore able
to smoke inside because every word
they're like yeah even in the plane it
was like one of their selling joins was
like you could smoke inside
now let's show you how old I am
I remember where they use have smoking
sexes smoking sections in the restaurant
or cigarettes every restaurant one that
Jim was like that oh yeah there's this
who she was put into it like in a coma -
because her lungs just stopped working I
wonder if she knew how to do the dope
like OHS you know like babes for like
three years or something like
consistently and then her lungs like
gave out and so now she wants to start a
baby no baby you're not even supposed to
smoke any oil or like ingest any oil cuz
your lungs people are doing like the
like the house or that's what we don't
know either I don't think so but I'm not
a scientist or expert I thought they
were saying here yeah like what kind of
campaign she want to take away
everyone's vapes
she should it be like don't they smoke
cigarettes instead she even had to stop
doing my essential oil diffuser diffuser
thing because um I found out that like
cats no which I have to I can't breathe
that air it like hurts their lungs so
even just that you have you motivated me
to stop using eucalyptus oil and oil
that because that shit's so amazing it's
like getting vapor rub in your lungs but
now no more vacations
[Music]
[Music]